i would like to speak to dr eric davis i
spoke to him briefly over email just had
a couple email exchanges but nothing
substantial i'd also like to speak to
jack sarfatti who also has his own ideas
as to how these tic-tac work
unfortunately dr safari also does
nothing highly
well it seems like each person is
uncomplimentary to the other
actually i think both of their works are
very interesting i wouldn't i i think
there is value in them both and they
should all be given
finances to follow
their theories
so from my perspective i think they're
worthwhile it's interesting how both of
them think mine is not it's uh
it hurts i'll tell you the truth i can
see that man and that alone puts you in
a great category that even though you're
being criticized that you're not willing
to criticize them or at least you know
the criticisms will will be laid
strictly at the work itself rather than
the person and that you still say that
hey even if i don't think this will work
they should be allowed to explore it and
perhaps it should even be funded to
explore it
i would never say something i don't
think that would work i think experiment
is essential improving whether
a physical theory is correct or not
and if anything fails experiment
then we should look not necessarily
abolish the theory just give up on the
theory but see whether there's something
we've missed
within the theory to make it
experimentally verifiable
it's too easy to give up on things that
i
again
i think a lot of physicists have given
up on philosophy which which
is essential i think physics without
philosophy is like a seed without water
fruitless
it's important
for physicists to also be philosophers
and i've always tried to
to have that this is why i love the work
of professor carlo robelli i think
professor carl rovelli is
also a great philosopher and there is
absolutely no stigma attached to that i
think
all great physicists at one point in
time were great philosophers look at uh
sir isaac newton look at uh
so roger bacon look at uh
um
why not yes look for example francis
bacon
francis bacon i'm i i i apologize so
roger penrose is what you're thinking of
and then you combine that yes i
understand
he also has a philosophy yes things so
roger penrose is amazing
it's a dr eric weinstein his uh uh he he
had a an interview i'm not sure whether
it's recent maybe a one-year-old
interview with siraja penrose before
sarajevo
yeah right on on on the portal i believe
it was very interesting
and and you can see the admiration and
sir roger penrose eyes
of dr y again dr weinstein his idea of
joy of geometric unity
why
must people say nay
give it a chance man i mean
this is what physics should be all about
i can't think of any other reason
other than
jealousy
i don't know
i
i
i never thought badly of anybody else's
work so i i cannot put myself in their
shoes and judge well the reason i said
that is because i see that in myself i
see there's so much jealousy in myself
and there's so much criticism that i do
of other people in my own head luckily i
i temper it and i try to stay away from
it
but
i
i see that quality in myself and so
it's
something i can identify in others
mainly because i suffer from that
perhaps to in
on an order of magnitude much larger
than the other people that i'm
saying suffer from the same
sins
i don't see that in you sir at all as a
matter of fact i i admire you greatly
and i admire the work that you do and i
hope series of everything podcast stays
on forever
because it's no you do a great service
to the community the guests that you've
had on are remarkable people with
remarkable ideas
i
i think if your podcast was ever to stop
i don't know what i would do in my free
time
i absolutely love it so
well that's just extremely kind of you
thank you so much
did you get to watch that podcast with
gross and david gross and carlo revelli
i have such admiration for both
gentlemen
very much so but
at one point in that interview when the
host
uh
calls um
professor rovelli uh
a poet
or something to do with philosophy
if you can see the expression on
professor gross's face just
i mean this is a nobel prize winner
one of the best physicists it was an
expression of what distaste was not
the
content more like of uh
something of that nature it was not
something that professor gross should be
associated with and i'm pretty sure that
he never meant to have that but for some
reason the host
had him you know had the
again philosophy should have never been
divorced from physics
period
unfortunately that divide
has been created
and as a result i think we've lost a
great deal
in physics
again these new ideas these uh
everybody wants new physics
why not new perspectives on old physics
there's nothing wrong with all physics
just because those books start smelling
musky at times doesn't mean you should
put them away